thank you to nordvpn for supporting pbs
wasps locusts spiders ants these insects
and the almost 900 000 others like them
make up 80 percent of the world's
species
seen or unseen the creepy crawlies
flying insects and burrowing creatures
are necessary to our ecosystems and can
contribute positively to our everyday
lives
but they can be devastating menaces
spreading disease and causing famine
despite my own misgivings when our
friends at deep look invited me to get
up close and personal with these
destructive insects i couldn't let you
all down and say no
there is perhaps no more infamous insect
swarm than the locusts
appearing in mass since at least the
days of ancient egypt the migrating
insects will tear through crops in their
hunger
tales of destructive locus plagues go
back thousands of years prominent in the
bible and the quran unsurprisingly these
real-life anxieties have been the
subjects of science fiction and horror
narratives for hundreds of years taking
on monstrous form
in edgar allan poe's the gold bug the
main character is driven to madness
after being bitten by a mysterious gold
beetle hgl's story the empire of the
ants features an intelligent aggressive
amazonian ant swarm one that will
purposefully attack humans
but bugs became visibly monstrous on
screen in the 1950s when the big bug
sub-genre of science fiction and horror
was hatched but why did this decade in
particular latch onto the idea of
freakishly monstrous bugs
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
the 1950s monstrous insect renaissance
peaked most notably with 1954's
them
while not the first of these bugs gone
rogue kind of films it was certainly the
most influential
them was a commercial and critical
success and was warner brothers highest
grossing film of 1954.
in the movie the fbi police government
officials and scientists discover a nest
of giant ants at a nuclear testing site
born in that swirling inferno of
radioactive dust were things so horrible
so terrifying
so hideous
there is no word to describe them
[Music]
they try to hide the discovery using
cyanide bombs but two queens survive
they in their offspring are driven from
the desert to the city of los angeles
where they are eventually killed with
flamethrowers by today's standards the
special effects and even the plot seem
underwhelming but at the time viewers
and film critics found the story
believable
one review from the new york times
described the film as tense absorbing
and surprisingly enough somewhat
convincing another from the saturday
review wrote that the film was as
persuasively realistic a horror story as
one could possibly imagine
why so convincing and realistic the
nuclear test site origins of the giant
ants make this movie a commentary on the
impact of atomic energy and nuclear
weapons while japanese kaiju films
emerge following world war ii as a
response to the horrors of the
destruction of nuclear bombs the
american-made them is more about the
unknown lingering effects of nuclear
testing and arguably the guilt felt for
developing and using nuclear weapons
many of the big bug films that followed
them incorporated nuclear weapons or
radiation like 1957's beginning of the
end which features massive locusts who
grew to a freakish size after eating
giant vegetables grown with radioactive
fertilizer
fertilizer produced by the u.s
government's experimental farm
as the locusts continue to feed on the
products of other radioactive
experiments their size continues to
increase
after they've torn through all vegetable
life they turn to humans
moving from the countryside into chicago
they destroy all in their path before
finally being lured to lake michigan and
killed the lingering effects of atomic
energy and nuclear weapons weren't the
only cultural commentary present in
these films
between 1940 and 1970 as part of the
great migration over 4 million black
americans move from the south to cities
in the northeast and west like chicago
new york detroit and los angeles
the height of this migration the 1950s
was marked by a period of what is
commonly referred to as white flight the
increased movement of millions of white
americans away from inner cities to
newly constructed suburbs these movies
mirrored the anxieties of white
audiences who viewed the great migration
as a type of invasion a theory supported
by the very real violence why urbanites
inflicted on minority residents and some
science fiction films seem to
intentionally support this racist
viewpoint driven in part by federal
policy and economic processes the
socioeconomic divide between white and
non-white citizens was reinforced and
broadened by the physical movement of
both populations
this movement is mirrored in the
on-screen insects journey from a more
rural landscape to suburbs or cities the
post-war movement's outline of racial
segregation also seemed significant the
brown v board of education ruling was in
1954 the same year then became a box
office success these big bug movies have
also been read as a response to growing
fears of communism from the cold war
with the insects standing in as a
metaphor for perceived foreign predators
secretly embedded in society
invading quietly before rising in mass
to destroy americans some of these films
suggest this more explicitly like in the
deadly mantis where the titular bugs
movements from the arctic circle are
detected on radar meant to monitor the
russian military
these films also play on the fear of the
crowd the concept of the crowd only
solidified at the turn of the 20th
century when industrialization and
urbanization contributed to the
collective anxiety of the masses of
being a cog in the machine on screen
these masses became invading aliens and
swarms of insects in the naked jungle
the ants aren't abnormally sized or
mutated there are just a lot of them a
massive 40 square mile size swarm the
giant wasp swarm created from cosmic
rays and the monster from green hell is
another example while many big bug films
featured singular monstrous arthropods
like the black scorpion tarantula and
earth versus the spider those creatures
real-life counterparts are poisonous to
humans
it is the smaller bugs that swarm in
these films it is the masses that are
more difficult to defeat
another interpretation that focuses on
the arthropods at the heart of these
movies is the cultural conversation
surrounding the pesticide industry in an
era of literal movement from rural to
city or city to suburb where the
domestic space was prioritized people
were freaked out about regulating bug
populations
the 1950s marked a boom in pest control
with etymologists agricultural
associations and government
organizations not to mention chemical
executives promoting the destructive
potential of insects
even small seemingly harmless
populations of bugs that live quietly
below ground largely out of sight of
humans could become a physical threat as
their populations literally grew
increased populations of locusts
japanese beetles boll weevils fire ants
and gypsy moths were all targeted in the
united states during the 50s the desire
to eradicate these creatures was even
referred to as the war on insects
when ddt was developed as a synthetic
insecticide in the 1940s it was
literally promoted as the atomic bomb of
insecticides but by the time the big bug
films emerged it was already becoming
apparent that not only did these
chemicals have a negative effect on all
life they also weren't as effective as
previously believed some of the big bug
films even incorporated this revelation
showing large dosing of insecticides to
have little effect on the creatures tell
them we need
ddt no good that stuff just stunned it
to put it simply insects were everywhere
and we wanted them dead the defeat of
giant insects on the silver screen was a
welcome image the role of the military
in these films is also interesting while
plot details often include government
cover-ups or secret experiments in the
same films the military ends up killing
the insects and saving the day science
is portrayed similarly while a mad
scientist is behind the helm of the
insects mutations other scientists are
responsible for coming up with the
solutions to eliminate them
1953's mesa of lost women features
mutant spider women and giant spiders
created by a scientist's pituitary
experiments he has human beauty and
intelligence
still possesses the capacities and
instincts of the giant spider tarantula
scientists possessed altruistic motives
his experiments aimed at combating world
hunger and increasing lifespan
likewise beginning of the end scientists
also wanted to solve world hunger with
radiation the big bug films also
presented audiences with a basic fear
these were creatures that they could
encounter in their own backyards while
giant rampaging lizards aliens and deep
sea creatures were scary they also
maintained a greater sense of escapism
insects on the other hand are part of
daily life while insects aren't going to
hunt down humans to eat them alive they
do pose a threat
besides the obvious poisonous ones and
their harmful bites swarms of insects
can also damage human lives and
livelihoods while honeybees gnats and
termites are all among the species that
swarm one of the most damaging and
notorious species is fire ants
fire ants swarm is part of their
reproductive cycle forming strange
floating masses their powerful bites and
painful stings make them a threat to
humans and animals and they can decimate
crops
originally from south america following
world war one fire ants traveled to the
united states but it wasn't until you
guessed it the 1950s when the invasion
gained attention
in 1957 the federal government targeted
fire ants with their own bug-killing
propaganda films so what about stories
featuring our beloved locusts
locusts are actually a variety of
grasshopper species that undergo
dramatic transformation when
environmental circumstances are just
right and locust swarms can number into
the billions
so i went to a lab to learn about locus
and ended up holding one
i may or may not have screamed one
unexpectedly jumped on me
i could feel its little claw tips i
hated it
after 1957's beginning of the end locus
interestingly faded away from science
fiction narratives until the 21st
century
as global warming causes locust swarms
to increase we have again found them on
our screen
but it's not just these monstrous flying
creatures that endure
following their golden era in the 1950s
big bug horror continuously plagues
horror narratives
from the mist to eight-legged freaks the
swarm to arachnophobia it doesn't seem
like we will be squashing these monsters
anytime soon but after all it's hard to
dismiss something that infiltrates our
lives every day seen or unseen we live
in a buggy bug world thanks again to our
friends over at deep look for their
really close-up view of the locust most
of the time desert locusts are solitary
mild-mannered insects but under just the
right conditions they have an explosive
dark side
those conditions trigger a hormone that
changes their bodies and behavior
creating plagues of biblical proportions
and guess what your body makes that same
hormone check out this new episode from
deep look that gets up close and
personal with these incredible insects
we'd like to thank nordvpn for
supporting pbs imagine vpn as a secure
encrypted tunnel for online traffic to
flow
nobody can see through the tunnel and
get their hands on your internet data
nordvpn allows you to use public wi-fi
in coffee shops or hotels or anywhere
else that you're on someone else's
network that way you can access personal
and work accounts on the road or simply
keep your browsing history to yourself
with nordvpn your one account lets you
connect securely up to six devices they
don't log your activity while you're
online they've got thousands of servers
in 60 countries and 24 7 customer
support to learn more about nordvpn just
check out nordvpn.com
[Music]
punches